[Musique]
et honnêtement quand on a appris qu
emmanuel macron s'exprimer demain on a
tous compris que c'était sans doute pas
pour nous dire que tout va bien on va
encore se faire engueuler voilà comment
une internaute résume le sentiment
général sur twitter en apprenant qu
emmanuel macron va donner une interview
demain soir certains se préparent à des
mesures drastiques 1 le hashtag rock
confinement faisait partie hier des mots
clés les plus discutés sur twitter
toutes les options sont pour le moment
sur la table des reconfirme en locaux
des limitations de déplacements ou en
ultime recours des couvre feux en
fonction de la situation ville par ville
département par département
certains imaginent des annonces plus
surprenante de la part du chef de l'état
mercredi soir à mon avis il va déclarer
ouverte la saison de la raclette diane
internautes ça se trouve il va dévoiler
l'iphone 12 temps un autre
et puis selon un supporters rennais il
va annoncer l'arrêt du championnat et
donc le sacre du stade rennais qui est
actuellement en tête de la ligue 1 bref
conclusion d'un internaute sur twitter
cette année on risque d'avoir un peu de
temps pour décorer le sapin de noël
cette nuit enfin hier soir le président
des états unis tenait son premier
meeting de campagne depuis qu'il a été
testés négatifs un rassemblement digne
d'une rock star personne ne portait de
masques ou presque ce qui je ne sais pas
mais en tout cas il a dit qu'il voulait
embrasser tout le monde j'ai traversé
cette épreuve
maintenant ils disent que je suis
immunisé je me sens si puissant j'ai
envie de traverser cette foule de tous
vous embrasser je veux embrasser les
hommes des jolies femmes
je veux tous vous embrasser
[Musique]
vim
[Applaudissements]
b
la remarque que la plus sexy ce que j'ai
entendu quand on fait mais son univers
et que donald trump arrivé qu'on doit
tout est habillé de la même manière et
qu'il arrive sur le devant de la scène
pour nous juger et qu'on m'avait dit
fais tous regardent ça j'avoue que
c'était vraiment une position sexiste je
trouve que c'est quand même très
problématique je fais on se dira les
gouvernements n'ont méchant parallèle
avec d'autres d'autres pays non mais
c'est pas parce que et non mais cela
c'est que vous allez envie d'entendre
que va continuer oui mais attendez des
trois minutes mais non mais non c'est
pas la semaine dernière vous avez fait
des tunnels pareil donc moi je viens
vous voir gagner sa place à mes
questions à la non mais vous ne pouvez
pas faire un cache l2 j'ai compris je le
vois plus rien je veux bien entendre
franchement clairement ça m'intéresse
pas c'est la journée internationale du
burger aujourd'hui une journée qui
devrait être fériés si vous voulez mon
avis mais ça c'est un autre débat
leberger donc on l'a déjà dit phénomène
culinaire en france ces dernières années
12 pour cent de croissance l'an dernier
les français en mangent en moyenne deux
par mois
[Applaudissements]
le pic de commandes en france pour les
burgers se situe à 19h57 précisément
tous les soirs même si comme le dit le
dicton dont je suis l'auteur il n'y a
pas d'heure pour un bon burger charles
35 mille exemplaires vendus depuis dix
jours depuis sa sortie ce en cours de
réimpression
et c'est un livre de quoi de
développement personnel c'est fait pour
toi
c'est un compte des conseils très uni m
captée dans les vestiaires de l'équipe
de france juste après la rencontre
contre le portugal regardez c'est
olivier giroud qui va dépasser gentiment
son coéquiper killian papé vous allez me
dire qui décoiffe ya pas beaucoup de
cheveux qui énorme ap mais bon regarder
sous sa tête il a l'air talent un brin
désabusé ans le jeune attaquant geste
amical
notre bon enfant dans les vestiaires
mais j'aurais aimé ça que je vois les
décalés maman était non pas d'ordre à la
légion on part se réfugier au grand
duché du luxembourg la france n'est plus
pour nous bien longtemps les valises on
s'en va moi je ne sais par la grande
bouche et c'est par là bas voilà enfin
travailler tranquillement
je décide de jouer voilà franc jeu avec
elle et de continuer sur cette ambiguïté
il et 2h15 du matin en californie quand
robert wilson sonne à la porte deux
pôles milgrom le chercheur américain
vient d'annoncer à son collègue et
voisin que tous les deux viennent de
remporter le prix nobel d'économie
attribué à stockholm en comme milgrom a
coupé son téléphone c'est le co
vainqueur qui est sorti en pleine nuit
accompagné de sa femme pour lui annoncer
la bonne nouvelle
yvon dénommée ils n'arrivent pas de juin
apparemment et non pas son numéro de
téléphone
il aurait tenu tout numéro de portable
oui ok cette scène inédite a été capturé
par une sonnette connectés et diffusée
par l'université de standford où les
deux hommes sont enseignants c'est moi j
je me noie dans ses yeux elle me dit une
phrase c'est pas sortis de leurs de
l'ordre des choses c'est un hippie qui
nous a mariés ibiza 1 balle juste après
ma séparation à moi on est parti à ibiza
tous les deux trois jours il ya un hic
si sur un marché qui nous avons dû deux
bagues et qui nous a mariés à larache
ah oui mais c'est pas un mariage
officiel il n'est pas du tout reconnu en
france oui elle de coeur d'accord les 40
hop au nom du père du fils de la weed et
du saint-esprit prix sonné par une
horrible odeurs d'urines pour découvrant
son impressionnante collection
les félins ont envahi tout l'appartement
une vingtaine dans la cuisine et presque
autant cacher dans le salon
au total ils seraient plus de 60 mois
tellement vous de ma vie la vérité je
plus quoi faire on va et sombre ben moi
je suis une rebelle anarchiste j'ai pas
les jambes
cette femme a dédié toute sa vie à ses
bêtes
toi le août nous ce qu'on veut c'est
sortir les choix de l'os et tout à la
fin de leur visite
franck et sa collègue sont convaincus
qu'il faut agir bien que tu passeras pas
aux images c'est vous dire on en a
terminé avec en fait vous étiez sur
balles il n'y avait plus rien sur le
prompteur donc ça veut dire que c'est
terminé